I'm attending one of the health
professional schools here
at BU.
And the prerequisites,
of course,
were, like, anatomy,
physiology, biology.
And yet--
Those are all
offensive and terrible.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
That seems to be the case.
We've discussed quite a
bit about transgenderism
and whatnot, even more than,
say, cardiovascular disease.
And we've even had assignments--
That makes sense, yeah.
I know, right?
We've even had assignments
where you would get docked off
or not get the points if you
didn't say that you would,
let's say, even
change their gender
and in the medical profile
to the gender that they say,
which I think is just
terrible, considering--
It's idiotic.
Yeah.
It's fully idiotic.
If it says on your
profile that you're
a member of the sex to
which you do not belong,
then you're going to get
profiled medically wrong.
Certainly.
If you're having lower stomach
pain, and it says on your chart
that you are a man, we're going
to be looking at indigestion.
If it says you're a
woman, we're going
to be looking at something else.
OK?
This is idiotic.
Yeah.
So going off that.
I guess you were
starting to discuss it.
I just wanted to know what
your opinion was on, sort of,
the implications of this.
Not only, like, a
culturally significant issue
that you've talked about more.
Invading it in more hardcore
science institutions,
especially considering
your wife's a doctor.
Yeah, she is.
As you may know.
Yeah.
So I think it's egregious.
I think that biology is biology.
It's amazing to
me that people who
proclaim that they
are scientists
are so willing to
overlook basic biology
and proclaim that people who
are fully biologically male
can magically become
biologically female.
We're not talking about
people who are intersex.
I always like when people who
debate this issue immediately
go to the marginal
issues where there actual
is blurring of the lines,
people who are intersex,
or they have some
genetic condition.
They have Klinefelter's
syndrome or something.
Right?
That's not what we're
talking about here.
The actual argument of the
transgender civil rights
movement is that people
who are fully male
can actually become
fully female.
That is obvious nonsense.
It's obviously nonsense.
And, again, the very
idea that a doctor
is supposed to sit
there and profile you
based on what you
wish you were is
so insane and stupid
and counterproductive.
I mean, if you're a
transgender person,
would you really want
the doctor profiling you
based along the lines of
organs you don't have?
If you're a biological man, do
you want to walk into a doctor,
and he's trying to figure
out how to fix your uterus?
You don't have one.
It's ridiculous.
[QUIET LAUGHTER]
That stuff is just
beyond the pale.
But it does demonstrate
the full-scale insanity
that now predominates.
And again, you know, I've
had this argument 1,000 times
with folks, obviously.
And the use of
politics above science
is obvious in everything from
what you're talking about,
to even the rewriting of the
Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual of the latest edition,
which is completely ascientific
based on no statistical
evidence and was essentially
a political decision to
relabel gender dysphoria
from a mental illness
or mental disorder,
it was called a mental disorder.
It's not a mental
disorder at all.
It's just the depression
associated with it
that's a mental disorder.
Well, by that
definition, schizophrenia
isn't a mental disorder.
It's only the depression
and suicidality
they go along with it that
are a mental disorder.
You can literally do that
with any mental disorder.
Again, for people who proclaim
that they care about science
and facts to say
this kind of stuff,
is ascientific and afactual.